me couper en deux
le teatro de marioupol en flammes
dévasté par un bombardement
ce bâtiment situé au centre de la ville
servait d'abri à des centaines de
personnes selon le maire
l'avion a largué une bombe sur le
bâtiment où s'abriter des centaines de
civils il est impossible d'établir le
bilan dans l'immédiat car les
bombardements des quartiers d'habitation
se poursuivront à moscou le ministère de
la défense a démenti ce soir avoir
bombardé sort grandi de marioupol il
accuse directement un bataillon
nationalistes ukrainiens
après deux semaines de siège la ville de
marioupol est défigurée dans cet hôpital
entre deux bombardements les blessés
c'est l'un des derniers centres de soin
rester debout faute de place il faut
soigner dans les couloirs
l'hôpital doit aussi remplacer la
maternité détruites il y a quelques
jours le sous sol s'est quant à lui
transformé en morgue plus de 2000 civils
sont morts depuis le début du siège
selon les autorités locales à l'aide
c'est une ville des bâtiments
résidentiels pour aider marioupol des
enfants des femmes sont tuées les
hôpitaux sont pleins à craquer on est
ici pour moi un génocide
près de trente mille habitants ont
réussi à quitter la ville en empruntant
des couloirs humanitaires
marie opole plus que jamais et ce soir
le symbole du drame que vit le peuple
ukrainien
impossible pour l'instant